I'm going to watch it first and then I'll verbally describe.
I'm thinking of feeling particularly in the sound of it.
Okay.
What do you need to pause?
Sounds great.
Okay.
Okay .
I think my tomiki was a little slow there.
That backdance was good.
That backdance was too forwards.
Yes.
This part felt nice.
But then the kicks, I was very aware that my kicks are a little awkward.
I bend my back knee.
The same there.
This part felt nice, but now I see my knees clumping a little bit.
Which is a bit awkward.
That stance, I need to fix that stance.
It's off.
Yeah, I definitely lost balance there.
That horse stance was better.
Six, seven.
I gotta make a fist sooner.
That's what I was thinking.
That's what I was thinking there.
I felt very good about the last part, though.
I think the last part was fine.
But I didn't judge my distance correctly.
I was half a step behind.
But I'm not that far ahead.
I have a better sense of direction now.
Yeah.
I think you can get used to it.
I was a little lost.
I think I was a little lost.
I don't know.